[Music]
[Applause]
fan Corrections is a segment where
viewers try to find mistakes on our show
all right so far many challengers no
winners we've never made a mistake
incredible I know it's amazing
well tonight a fan with the YouTube
screen name uber Martin says he thinks
he caught a mistake he says it happened
during a recent monologue when I was
talking about the u.s. men's soccer team
hey Gillman I was watching your show the
other night
and I couldn't help but notice that he
made what is commonly known as a mistake
he mistakenly referred to the United
States football soccer team as you call
it as having qualified for the World Cup
good news the US soccer team qualified
for the World Cup by beating Jamaica 1
to 0 in fact they are currently sitting
tied on points with Walla Walla and
Jamaica in their qualifying group and
have not qualified through that let
alone the qualifying group after or the
World Cup how do I know this obviously
because I'm not an American which also
explains how I know about the theory of
evolution anyway like to see how you get
out of this one Cheers
[Music]
well yeah sorry
uber Martin if that's your real name
but it turns out you're dead wrong I
didn't actually say that the US soccer
team had qualified for the World Cup and
if you had bothered to watch the rest of
the monologue you would know that check
it out
good news the US soccer team qualified
for the World Cup by beating Jamaica 1
to 0 is that all you have to say Conan
no Andy I'd like to add that in fact the
US soccer team is currently sitting tied
on points with Guatemala and Jamaica and
their qualifying group and I've not
qualified from that let alone the
qualifying group after or the World Cup
you sure know your soccer Koenen you
mean football
[Laughter]
we had a particularly large studio
audience yeah yeah it's great and
outdoors yeah out shut up by the way
uber Martin you say that Americans don't
know about evolution well guess what
you're wrong about that too here is
what's taught in every classroom in
America
[Music]
[Applause]
u.s.
it's so fun to be Mussolini for a second
well the challenge still stands if you
think you're smarter than ever on our
show report it team koco.com / ha ha I
found an era we will sort it out here on
the air let's see if you've got what it
takes to make chunk meat out of the
maestro
[Applause]